[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're talking about our
college experiences
and how that translates into the advice
that we're now giving to anyone who
cares to listen
and maybe mostly our children yeah
if they care to listen yeah they don't
usually lilly is on the precipice of
college
university life
uh she's on the quarter system so as of
the release of this she's still like
three weeks away
from going off to school now i do
anticipate
that i will share with you
my experience of
taking lily off to college and that so
that's an entirely different ear biscuit
that probably like a month from now
is going to come out but i'm definitely
in this head space of
every day is one less day we have her in
the house and there's kind of this like
i feel this urge
oh yeah i gotta tell her about this i
can only imagine i got it you're
becoming the i gotta warn her about this
overly sentimental dad who's giving
advice that makes everyone feel awkward
i haven't gotten into a tv trope
sentimental speech i mean i'm there's a
lot of emotion that's wrapped up and i'm
saving all of that for
for that ear biscuit later but i have
observed that like
i'm like oh crap it's like
i mean it's not like we're not going to
be in communication we're both still
going to have phones
uh but there is a sense of like she's
not going to be like an embedded
journalist in north korea is it no that
is not where she's stuck she's just
going to college
uh
but there is a sense of
if there's little packets of advice that
i can give you know what that's now the
time to do it literal packets advice
packets here's another folder honey
i put this one together last dossier
well honestly
i mean
we're talk we're talking about it a lot
but i think a lot of what i'm sharing
today i i i don't anticipate she's going
to listen to this podcast
but i'm kind of going to coalesce well
you shoot things off of you put it in a
packet make a text file and put it in
the packet no i'm going to i said i'm
going to run some things off of you like
but i what i meant was bounce some
things off of you you can run off and
then i don't care maybe i'll take maybe
if you have some advice well yeah yeah
maybe i think we're both
i think we're both bringing you're going
to be here too right right
we're both bringing equal and maybe uh i
mean who's advice is more valuable
that's for you to decide i'm going to
take credit for all of the advice that
i'm going to turn around and give to
lily after this one thing i do want to i
do want to say up front uh is there
there was a podcast in the past
in which we were talking about something
related to college and i think i gave
some unprompted and definitely
unsolicited advice
and got some feedback on twitter about
it and it was enlightening oh you got
feedback on twitter yeah that happens
yeah and uh and i do try to i do try to
listen you know i i'm we're just
throwing things out into the ether and
and we we do want to know when we've
uh we've gone out of bounds and i think
the the thing that people said was i
can't remember exactly what the point i
was making was but it was very much from
my personal experience
and
the way that college uh happened for me
which
isn't representative of everybody's
experience and you know my parents paid
for my college i didn't have to work
when i was going to college
um
i wasn't going through
it wasn't difficult for me from like an
emotional standpoint like a lot of
people are struggling with all kinds of
anxiety
and depression and social anxieties when
they go to college like i didn't have i
didn't have that it was like one of the
best times of my life right
and so
i come from uh
my experience is not going to be
representative of everybody's experience
and so
just i guess well ultimately what i'm
saying is that i understand that now and
so the things that we're going to talk
about today are not prescriptive it's
not necessarily advice first it's more
this is what we kind of thought that we
learned and as we think about our kids
going off to school these are some of
the principles and some of the things
that we'll be telling them that we
actually do think is good advice for
them
but you kind of have to take it and
filter it through your own personal
experience and don't take it as a
prescription from
a guy who had a pretty privileged
experience and you know what that's
that's
that's the message i agree with that i'm
going to do the same thing i think you
can apply that
uh
disclaimer to every episode of your
biscuits but there are certain points
when i mean we are saying this is advice
but as i talked to lily about things
a lot of i mean there is this dance of
this is my perspective try this on for
size but
my size doesn't fit you
at every turn so
it's a it's a dialogue and it's not
there's not an absolute in the way i
present things i mean
parenting at this age parenting an adult
in any form is kind of like what's going
on here but it i mean there's still
space for it but it feels much different
and it's and it's malleable and it's
more conversational and i think that's
that's part of what this twitter thing
is
it's part of the conversation that we
have on your biscuits wait you know
we don't present things as authority and
sometimes when it seems like we do
it's it's nice to hear
but it's not surprising for us to hear
that we we're only a representation of
our own experience and we're trying to
kind of just
put it out there within those boundaries
i think that parenting at this point
i i think that as your kid gets older
it's i and this is difficult for a
parent but you go from if you think
about like
let's just say a sports analogy you go
from being the coach
to being
the spectator
right there there is a there is a moment
there where you feel like hey things
that i say seem to seem to matter
and the rules that i establish they have
immediate impact seem to have immediate
impact
and then slowly you're like taking off
the softball shorts you've got other
pants you've got like parent pants you
take off the softball coach shorts and
you put on regular pants
probably probably khakis you take the
whistle and you and you give the whistle
to the referee or the you know and you
take the hat off and you you sit down in
the stands and you just yell a lot and
your kids probably aren't listening to
you
you're just embarrassing yourself and
the family i think this is kind of a
teaser for the conversation we'll have
after lily leaves so we can come back to
it but now let's just unabashedly get
into the cold hard advice that everybody
should take without question well i do
want whether you're going to college or
not before you go uh because i mean i
don't want you to miss the opportunity
to tell everybody that you are you've
made an appearance on a hot dog as a
sandwich the mythical kitchen podcast
josh and nicole have me on you can
listen to it now on on on the show a hot
dog is a sandwich talking about being a
picky eater
josh said at some point i don't know how
much they edit their podcast
so it may be edited out but what he said
to me in the middle of the podcast was
wow
this didn't go the way this isn't going
the way i thought it would
so
that's my that's my teaser i don't i
haven't talked to josh about it i might
have to listen now but um
yeah it was apparently not how what he
expected from the conversation
i i and i don't know if that's a good
thing did it get really serious uh i
guess so yeah
oh really that was it yeah
wow i don't maybe so you guys maybe he
would use other terms you got like
therapeutic
uh i might have gotten defensive
oh
okay i i didn't think i was going to
come across that way so you'll have to
be the be the judge of it it was it was
a good conversation
i really enjoyed it i have no regrets
okay um
i just don't know if they do
i should talk to them about it
you should find out hot dog is a
sandwich check it out uh they do food
debates every week when they don't have
a guest which is uh unusual
to have a guest
but it does happen
all right um
i mean yeah for our experience we went
to north carolina state university
in in the fall of 1996
things were different then we drove
it was like a 45 minute drive from our
home
i was roommates with my best friend
since first grade hey that's me
and
we didn't really know anybody else but
we knew that we were going to get
involved in
an organization called campus crusade
and i i think that that would as we
talked about that defines a big part of
our least that organization as well as
we'll share later yeah that's right um
and
i had well just to set the stage even
further
i had a serious girlfriend who was a
junior in high school
and
i would go home every weekend to see her
and also to get my laundry done and to
pick up all the cans of mellow yellow
that my mom had bought me
mel yellow was not available in raleigh
it was but we had to buy it with your
own money
right uh i did have a job on campus i
worked at the genetics lab like the work
study program i was washing the dishes
of the um
the scientists who were doing some sort
of genetic experiments on corn
i then had to clean all the beakers and
test tubes and that's a meticulous
process if you're sure they weren't
eating corn and you were cleaning their
actual dishes i think that's that's
possible i think they were selling you
on like you're involved in the science
here and you're just washing dishes of
scientists you like corn yeah i mean if
they were feeding themselves with
pipettes then i guess that's what i've
seen that happen one one kernel at a
time
it's a great way to eat corn it really
helps with portion control we had
visited campus once
at least i think michael jubie
michael jubie's dad
took us to campus our senior year and
like we walked around campus well we
only applied
to two schools carolina and state
uh both were accepted to both i thought
we applied to
uh unc asheville to their film school we
didn't actually know we didn't actually
apply we were going to but we got talked
about that was like that was more junior
year
conversation when i thought i might play
basketball there
but no in the end we only applied to
carolina in state and that's not
accepted in engineering there was
serious consideration of going to
carolina i mean i the story i tell is
i applied to carolina so that i could
get accepted and then say no to reject
them but the reality is
i was not like a loyal state fan versus
carolina i was actually sort of like
growing up a duke fan i was a state fan
you were a state fan and i didn't i
didn't really felt like i couldn't do it
i didn't have a lot of carolina
allegiance but one boy once i
died my
backside in the wolf pack red i think
that's how you do it you stick your butt
in the blood when you get there just
kind of dip it uh the wolf blood there
was no going back no wolf dyed the blue
the entire pack donated a little bit of
blood so they were they were a little
peakish for a few days but they you know
no wolves were harmed
ultimately in the butt dipping of blood
i remember that we we both brought our
bikes to campus we've oh it's like we
had never been on a place so large that
you were expected to walk across the
whole thing well we've been riding our
bikes a lot just we always rode our
bikes it was part of our
identity it was part of our brand was
we're boys with bikes well once we got
licenses not so much but
but i think someone had told us like
that's a really big campus and you guys
are way over there on east campus in
syme dorm
so i mean it's going to take you you
know a couple of days to get to the
other side of campus if you have to walk
well to get to the dining room it did
take
i mean it probably took 20 minutes to
walk to just walk straight yeah
all the way across campus to the dining
hall
which that was that was fun you know
having that excursion that bagged milk
like see seeing
like who from your dorm you could get to
get together with and i'll leave at the
same time oh we're still waiting for
hugh where's hugh
he's up there being weird
in his dorm room we're gonna have to
leave him
remember hugh
unfortunately i don't
must have been not maybe that wasn't
memorable
he's an interesting guy am i grant grant
oh
you grant he's an actor yeah grant is
his name not hugh
who where's you i don't know a hugh
maybe maybe he would show up if
i knew his name was grant um but yeah
we'd ride our bikes all around campus
but the thing now that i superimpose on
the experience
is just what an opportunity for
a
i'll call it a fresh start
it's it's just an opportunity to
redefine yourself if you've ever had one
if you i mean
this is it if you're going off to
college and you know
no one or you know we had to be in
cahoots because we knew each other if i
was going to change my name or adopt a
french accent or start wearing a
different type of pants
this is the time this is the time to do
it the name thing is a big one
a lot of people
this is my opinion
okay
if you're going to change your name you
don't like your name and you want to go
by your middle name or you don't like
your middle name you want to make your
first name you want to go buy a new
nickname jazz this is kind of the last
acceptable place to do it
if you wait until you're out of college
and like you got a job and then just one
day you're like my name is mark now
that's tough to do i mean we knew a chip
who changed his name to peter
and that was in middle school but chip
chip is a nickname that your dad gives
you chip off the old block you know or
maybe you're a tray if you're a third
which you could have named you could
have been a tray
you could be a tray like you could have
changed your name to trey
because trey is when you're not a junior
but a third that's right you they're in
an alternate universe
there's a there's a rhett and tray.com
man
i know that's not our website anymore
but james it does redirect a mythical
document but jane it'd probably be james
james
there's a jameson tray there's a hey
listen there's a tray in james chaz and
james
you could have been a chaz
this is the time to do it don't wait
until now if you transfer colleges maybe
at that point yeah that would that's the
reason to transfer because you're not
happy with your name or like what type
of pants you're known for or if you're
like i'm gonna start you know i'm gonna
get i'm gonna get one earring or i'm
gonna start painting my nails
whatever you wanna do do it
but this is really and i'm not saying
you can't do any of those things later
but like this is the real time we show
up on campus with like a
scarf
and you know i mean like one of your
eyebrows shave down the middle and just
call me mark now we're kind of talking
about two sides of our mouth because
when we when we went to uh college i
didn't do this by the way well we kept
we did it a little earlier but i do
think we
we fully asserted ourselves
i mean we were very much dedicated to
our band the wax paper dogs
and our so
in our senior year of high school and
throughout that summer before our
freshman year like we had gigs we had
the biggest gigs that we had had biggest
games i mean
we're talking like
the christian
indie band circuit
centered around
uh
harnett county we played on humber
we played on that stageville north
carolina in benson
in that park and benson yeah that's
probably not the second terrible biggest
soldier to mule days yeah we played on
that stage but we
i mean we were
bleaching our hair
and like you were i was i was turning
your hair into like a giraffe pattern
that looked absolutely amazing but was
mistaken as a soccer ball we would i'm
how many saw girls black and yellow some
but
i mean it's a giraffe come on i knew it
was a draft but i'm saying a lot of
people thought it was red white and blue
for july 4th over that the summer
leading into our yeah got to be
patriotic freshman year in college so
like we were wearing
these the huge jinko jeans with the
chain
wallet
and
uh
the thrift store shirts like the thrift
store golf shirts yeah and our and our
hair
what my hair was like standing up and
and bleached
and that even went into my sophomore
year because that's when christy and i
met and like
the last time my hair was like big and
bleached was when we first met and then
it started to tone down
over the course of becoming a
professional well we weren't in the band
anymore but like as freshmen
like we had a very assertive looks
you know i mean you were tall as all get
out and and and
scarily skinny right and with these huge
jeans it just looks i mean you're we're
riding these bikes around i look like
gumby i mean were those jeans i never
really thought about
the you know i enjoyed
getting attention for the way that i
looked
but at the same time this may be hard to
believe at the same time i do not
honestly recall having this awareness
that everyone was looking at me as i
rode my bike across campus but
we
we were some of the more aesthetically
notable people on campus i'm not saying
we were cool looking we were just
different
but to put that in proper context it
wasn't that difficult in 1996 at nc
state university to stand out just to
stand out
you know it's probably much more
difficult today we stood out more than i
thought i did in my own mind
even though i did it him on purpose i
don't know it's just weird how i can
hold those two truths but so we didn't i
didn't
make a switch
we kind of doubled down i think with the
way that we looked so it was just like i
think
hearing friends talk about it later they
were like wow these guys are different
these guys are weird maybe a healthier
way to think about it is
less of
take this as an opportunity to reinvent
yourself reinvention for the sake of
reinvention is not going to last right
it's got to be motivated by something
but maybe it's taking a look at what
things about you um
do you want to leave behind in your in
your former self right into the high
school self you're not bringing that
business with you to college and maybe
sometimes something like
a name change or an aesthetic change can
be symbolic of that
you know the external stuff is not
really that important but that's true
yeah it can be a growth exercise and it
also applies to starting a new job yeah
i think most all of this applies so
there's other points
it's like and if you have a new child so
i would be a different person to this
child call me mark son
so i'm trying to think of other
opportunities where you can like
completely reinvent yourself you know if
you go on a vacation you could you could
have a trial run with a new self or a
new name well it's like the time we went
to emerald point water park in
greensboro and acted like we were from
liverpool
hello ladies
you know where the beat oh from the
redneck girls that we were hitting on
didn't know how bad our
liverpoolian accents were and so they
just went with it
followed us around all day we went with
it and that was there and then we got
into our little bowie street first
baptist van
gaal because we were there with our our
church group
it's like
they were like first of all watched from
liverpool are in the van why did you
ditch everyone else with the church
group and why when we would see you in
different lines for slides and stuff
like that you were with these two girls
and you had a bad british accent and you
would never talk to us because we even
reinvented ourselves for the water park
you should try it too i mean in college
what an [ __ ] move i think listen i
stand by that well yeah cause you're
only thinking about you but we were
there with a group and they were our
friends i'm not we didn't completely
abandon them i saw them in the lockers
[Laughter]
so
this is this is an opportunity
yeah
we also have an opportunity to promote
our merch
well and this is pretty exciting i mean
listen we're doing a a collab with
masters of the universe i'm wearing the
purple version of the shirt right now
okay he's masters of the mythical
universe
here and skele link high fiving high
fiving
i mean our friendship even transcends
the the the he-man universe and brings
together these two characters that would
never have right yeah they've reinvented
themselves
uh you can get this is an official
collab
we've got
the purple option which link is wearing
and we've got the black option if you're
feeling
you know a little dangerous if you feel
like you have the power
and or if your name is mark
uh so pick that up mythical.com while
it's available i mean this is not going
to be around forever this is a collab
y'all going to college is like your
opportunity to go from being cringer to
being battle cat you know what i'm
saying right from what you need is a
helmet cyclops to being tila
um okay
another thing that i think is important
and this could seem a little bit cliche
so we'll get into some specifics
is the whole idea of making friends now
yes i think that this is worth saying
because especially now like things have
changed and everyone's experience is
different and you know lots of people
are uh commuting to school living off
campus uh living at home
for for a multitude of reasons and so it
can be
more difficult when you've got some of
these other circumstances than if you
just you know
you drop somebody off at college in
another town
and they've got to sort of make their
own way it's easier in that scenario
but i think especially if you are the
kind of person that it's not easy for
you to make friends
um
and you you know
you've got anxiety around expanding your
social circle or whatever your
particular challenges would be
i just think this idea of opening
yourself up with discretion and wisdom
of course you don't want to get involved
in the wrong crowd of marks or anything
like that i was thinking marxist when
you said that well yeah when you're
going to college you're going to get
involved with some marxism
that's part of it man
but
letting your just
letting yourself be a friend to someone
and also
letting someone else be a friend to you
it has to be a conscious decision i
agree i'll lower the bar lower the ball
and try to gamify it a little bit here's
the idea that i've come up with
collecting acquaintances
i'm pretty excited about this so don't
poo poo it i'm talking about making a
list of the types of people that you
want to know and not necessarily be
friends with or commit to but just know
just acquaintances like uh
i want to know
i want to know a weird person
i want to know like a really brainy
person i want to i want to know a
foreign exchange student
what about that i want to know
i want to know an upperclassman so it's
like you you make this list of the types
of people that you want to know because
don't write it down though people find
that list don't write it on your hand
and then check it off when you're number
seven you know what i've always wanted
to meet
like
um someone majoring in biology who
wears suspenders okay i think most of
them do that's not something you want to
say to someone a biology
suspender-wearing major you know i
always wanted to you were on my list
yeah just i mean but actually
maybe you could say that
who would you add to your list um let's
start making this list now if we had to
go back
i want to i want to i want to meet a
bleach-haired bicycle riding
strange guy well taking i i do believe
that i do believe that you are serious
in your uh
in this in this piece of advice i'm
going to take it seriously it's nice to
have a variety of people in your life to
be exposed i mean well i think it's an
opportunity to expose yourself
not in that way i wish that we would
have taken this now we'll talk a little
bit later about another principle that i
think is important which is kind of
throwing yourself into a cause while
you're in college which we definitely
did in a very big way yeah um but given
the nature of the thing that we got
involved with which was campus you know
christian campus ministry
we got involved with a lot of people
from very similar backgrounds on very
similar trajectories
as we were right
and i think the thing that i regret
is not intentionally connecting with
people who were different than me of
course nc state was different in 1996
but it wasn't that different there were
people from all walks of life from all
socio and economic backgrounds from all
over the world
all kinds of interesting perspectives
and things that were being exchanged and
we closed ourselves off
right into the
you know
southern white conservative christian uh
heterosexual group you know what i'm
saying and just went real real hard at
that
uh and i wish that i could have been
like oh and but my mentality was not my
mentality going into college at the time
was one of other perspectives are not
only different but necessarily wrong
i'm coming to this campus with the truth
i'm bringing
the correct world view to this worldly
place and when you go into a situation
believing that you've got the truth and
it is your job to dispense the truth to
the worldly corrupted people around you
yeah
making connections with them becomes a
transactional thing where the only
reason you're not really conducive to
true friendship you make it you make it
becomes transactional because i'm only
befriending you so that i can share the
gospel with you so that i can tell you
what the truth is
and most people aren't receptive to that
so you end up just hanging out with all
the conservative white people who are
receptive to that who believe the same
thing it's a problem so i wish i hadn't
done that right yeah and all we had to
do was make a list of acquaintances you
don't have to make it this weighty thing
where it's like i have to i have to
build meaningful long-lasting
friendships with all these different
type of people that you know that sets
the bar really high and it's
intimidating but just having one one
conversation with somebody you know in
the first couple of weeks on campus
there's this thing that we've talked
about called campus face yeah
you just need to know that it's going to
happen if you're on that type of campus
where you're walking around and you
you're seeing the same faces over the
course of a year
and at a certain point you realize
i know this person's face but i've never
met them or talked to them
and it's nice to have a few people that
you've at least said something to like
uh leaned over in class and said like
have you
is this your first time taking chemistry
i just made that up on top of my head
because then it's like if it's chemistry
101 probably okay it's a stupid question
yeah
that would be my follow-up your name
mark that was just a stupid question
whoever wanted it to be just to ask you
just just so i could like break the ice
do you have any pets i you know i think
so some another type of person that's on
my list and it would also take the heat
off of the criticism we placed on
ourselves that you just laid on us and
we deserve it is athletes
like i would like i would put an athlete
on my list or maybe you'd be my i want
to be friends with a football player and
i want to be friends with a track and
field artist artist that's the correct
term or a graffiti artist that's someone
i would like to know in my life now i
think i think i can make a list of
acquaintances now yeah this is not
pretty much a principle to apply to the
artist
is is gonna be in the top five for me
but athletes had attendance they they
lived in this bubble on campus which we
penetrated because we were so far from
the dining hall
that they allowed us
at the extreme east side of campus to go
to the much closer
athletic dining hall case case dining
hall named after a coach everett casey
much smaller
it was much better food much better food
they had steaks
and it was only athletes except for the
people from our like the three dorms way
over there where we were yeah and so
it's like these scrawny kids in like
really huge clubs
i was mistaken as a member of the
basketball team many times so don't
don't
don't put me into the scrawny kids with
big clothes groups i was thought that
you were the manager
for the for the basketball team but they
thought i was on the basketball team and
i went with that okay the lunch ladies
did
but the other athletes knew who was on
the basketball team and you weren't one
of them so it was like yeah we actually
got these strange looks and we stopped
going but i went there enough to know
and we had we did have a few
athlete friends we had a football player
friend our roommates not roommates but
are right next door we're both on the
football team and then uh
jackie was a swimmer yeah and they're so
isolated they're in this bubble they do
nothing but sports i mean so it really
goes for them too they need to make a
list of like hey i need to have a couple
of acquaintances
who
aren't
athletic well now so that i can realize
that the world is much
broader but now they can ncaa athletes
can get sponsored
so now you can like hang out with
somebody who's got like a deal with like
the local italian restaurant
you know and maybe get a free
free pasta um
i got some stuff on
breaking the ice and having
conversations that first week of class
you need to you need to introduce
yourself to a stranger in every class in
the first week it's leaning over and
saying something just so because you
know you're going to be in class with
these people if it's one of i mean chem
101 as an example it could have been a
thousand people in that classroom no
that's not true there could have been
300 people in that classroom now you're
getting closer okay that's still a lot
of people yeah
but it would have been better if you
just gone with a towel okay
but you're going to see all these people
and you're pr but at a in a large
classroom you're tempted to never talk
to anybody unless they force you into
groups which they usually don't and so
it's like just breaking the ice for a
conversation what it does is even if
it's just hey my name's link i just
wanted to uh introduce myself because i
know you know we're going to be in class
and i oh it starts a conversation
it basic starting a conversation opens
up the door for someone else to more
easily talk to you later and you
typically sit in the same you don't have
to
i don't actually remember this but for
whatever reason we ended up sitting in
the same places in all the classes no
matter how big the rooms were creatures
have happened uh and so you do yeah and
i was like oh man i was sitting next to
this person
basically all year and when you make
this is the thing you got to do it in
the first week like you said because
when you wait like if you initiate a
conversation with somebody third week
it's like whoa whoa what
you know yeah now if you haven't
initiated in the third week still do it
but just know that it's going to be
harder
you need to do this needs to be pretty
early like right out of the gate and
then yeah okay maybe you have an initial
uh awkward conversation but
next time if they're going to initiate
the conversation with you
and if they don't you'll be like oh i'll
talk you got it you go to the left side
talk to the person on the left side i
mean
there was a time on good mythical
morning where we talked about miss
perfect as we called her
ad nauseum but it's worth bringing up
again that like you know jill wagner
later host of
wipeout and now
uh she's like a hallmark specialist
hallmark movie star yeah uh
you know we got teen wolf oh yeah also
on team sorry yes don't want to sell
jill shorts we're fans of the person not
the actress
um she was very sweet and came on our
show and like endured some some awkward
exercises for the sake of comedy but we
could have actually you know it's we
were intimidated and we didn't want to
talk to her so we just talked about her
but we could have actually been friends
i mean it's not like it would it just
had to be
oh i think you're
pretty so now we can't be friends well
we i was thinking more than friends
personally but yeah or you could have
had i want to move beyond acquaintances
i i agree with everything that you're
saying but i i think that just trying to
ease them into it but i but
what i'm getting at is and i think we
did again
all that we said before
you know notwithstanding if that's the
correct use of the word i try to avoid
giving the disclaimer unless it's a a
legal document
um no i'm saying that like i didn't we
got involved with a particular type of
people but
the thing that you left out is yes we
got involved with campus crusade but we
also we got involved with intervarsity
as well another christian campus
organization because they had a bible
study in our dorm that was a co-ed bible
study intervarsity was like living wild
men and women studying the bible
together what could happen
crazy
and so we got involved in that group and
uh ended up like that fall going on a
ski trip with that group of people and
they were like a really that was like
our really
probably our strongest friend group at
the time freshman year and i just think
the idea of being like hey we got here a
few weeks ago
and now we're all getting in a car and
going up to the mountains to
ski and eat spaghetti together and like
these were things that we had not done
yeah we had never gone on a trip with
our friends overnight like we didn't
have that yeah we just didn't do that as
high school students so it was uh but it
was it was a real it was a real
connection
and for reasons basically essentially
the only the only reason is because we
decided to kind of go all in with campus
crusade on our sophomore year and so
that that connection with them in that
bible study was severed a little bit and
they just became just like less close
friends
that idea of really saying hey i'm gonna
move yeah the the the the strategy that
you're talking about with acquaintances
is to
give yourself the social network the
largest
you know
a number of options for who am i
actually gonna be friends with yeah but
there is a again this is difficult for a
lot of people
there's a barrier to be like i'm going
to actually become your friend it's
going to be more than a conversation in
class let's go do something together oh
here we are we're going on a ski trip
together and this has got to be done
with discretion because sometimes you
get involved with some weird people
especially
the thing that happens a lot of times in
freshman year depending on what kind of
school you go to
a lot of times you've got the freshmen
who are there who are just there to
party and
you can kind of get sucked into that and
then when they flunk out a lot of times
they take a lot of people with them so
you gotta you you got to be you got to
use some wisdom
but i think that this idea of really
learning what a friendship
and this may not be something that
you've done maybe you didn't have this
type of friendship with somebody in high
school
um but becoming a part of someone's life
so that the idea of going on a trip
together or saying hey fall break's
coming up we're not going back home
we're all going somewhere together like
having that option
planting the right kinds of seeds with
acquaintances that become friends that
become deeper friends that become people
that you're going to know for the rest
of your life
i think you got to go in with that
mentality
especially like you know that wasn't
that's not our that's not that's not a
challenge for us like we we tend to kind
of just go all in and get really
personal and deep with people very very
quickly and we've always been that way
so we make fast friends but that's
that's kind of an exceptional way to
approach it if that's not a natural
instinct i think you've just got to go
in
and say i know my instinct is to isolate
and to pull away
and next thing you know
you're getting ready to go back your
sophomore year and you're like i don't
feel like i know anybody yeah i don't
even know if i want to go back i mean
lily
had the option to put down a preference
for
i mean they did this whole like
personality analysis of like what time
do you wake up in the morning what time
do you go to bed what you know what is
how do you
what is your view on
alcohol
uh you know it's it's not allowed on
campus anyway but still it's not allowed
that's my view it's a good question you
know lots of things like that you get a
sense of the person's sensibility so you
they can pair you up with roommates that
would
increase the likelihood of compatibility
um you want the person who's going to
sneak in alcohol with you but you can
also request
to to to stay in a a dorm room alone
like that was an actual option there's
also an option to like have a roommate
or an option to have five roommates
where she's going yeah there's there's
like a big room yeah one big room not a
suite like one big room with two bunk
beds and another bed
that seems crazy i think that's overkill
but
i mean i mean that's like maybe that's
military bombs yeah it's bunks but i
guess some people would be into that
like camp life type situation
but i was glad that
lily didn't she she was tempted to say
as an introvert i want to have my own
room
but instead when she was assigned to
her certain part of campus it was like
there's like a a large assignment to a
certain part of campus and then
underneath that then you have dorm
assignments and she was able to connect
with
other people who were given that
umbrella assignment to this area of
campus on instagram like everybody
started
started following that account to that
area of campus she's gonna be rooming
with a biology major who wears
suspenders
no she's rooming with somebody who is
also an introvert who was tempted to
have to request a room by herself and
is also really into
the star wars
animated series so oh we're like i spent
a lot of time deep in the fandom
so it's there's a connection that's cool
we didn't we didn't have those tools
they started talking over instagram and
then over text and
um i was like have you did you video
chat
she was like not yet not yet you know
but it's like ultimately they were like
you know what we know enough about each
other to request each other versus just
going potluck well and the reason i
think that this is now obviously we room
with each other
so it's a little bit different i wanted
a biology major in suspenders but i got
a link uh no we chose each other and
that made it it got weird when you made
me talk about biology and wear
suspenders
especially
nothing but suspenders and there was no
place to fasten them
there is a place to fasten them but you
got to be careful
please erase that mental picture
we didn't have to worry about this
because we knew we were going to room
with each other but here's why i think
that
making the decision to have roommates is
so important even for us
each one of us now you're an only child
i i had one brother but he was in a
different room and we kind of minded our
own business
i i i am of the opinion
that
developing the life skill of sharing a
living space with another adult is a is
an important thing to develop because
chances are right whether you're going
to have roommates to help you pay your
rent or you're going to you know get
into a relationship where you move in
with somebody you get married
you're probably going to share a living
space with somebody later in life and
this is the time to learn what that's
like and the thing that is so
interesting because me and you as we've
gotten older have gotten more rhett and
more link than we were when we were sure
uh freshman in college because we all
know
that you're really concerned about
order and cleanliness and i'm not really
but
that wasn't
it i don't remember that being like a
big point of contention and conversation
or like stress
in our relationship because right i
don't went along with it maybe it was we
just didn't we didn't have enough things
in the room to create like chaos and i
actually didn't we we also it was our
living space that opened up into a
public space that people could just walk
by so i didn't feel like it was my
bedroom that i could just make all dirty
it was like oh we leave our door that's
another thing we left our door open to
our dorm room which uh i do recommend
um right and unless you're wrestling
which we were doing one time and it was
a little awkward we were really into ufc
long story um yeah link was wearing
nothing but suspenders i thought the
door was cracked i know i thought it was
shut but it was cracked we left our door
open a little bit and but when you laid
on me because that's your yeah your
wrestling that's my ufc move that's my
submission i mean i do i don't remember
how we told the story before but we told
the story
15 times we're sure in public i mean you
were doing the i'm dead yeah yeah
and then i looked over your shoulder not
being able to move anything except my
head yeah that's part of the plan and i
looked in the crack of the door and
granted it was grant hugh looking in and
i and i made eye contact with him
and then he walked away he accepted it
though there was no ex
there
that was one of the cool things about
grant there's no judgment i think he i
think he thought he knew what was
happening which
to clarify wasn't happening it wasn't
happening but he didn't care i i really
got to give it to him well i don't want
to give it to him but thank you grant
so anyway
yeah we we learned a lot i think we did
uh i think it prepared us and i think
yeah even
subsequent to sharing the dorm room when
we moved into an apartment and then we
added greg and then we added tim
uh i think that each one of those
iterations was about sharing a space
and it's just like just there's a
tendency again you a a lot of folks i
get it you wanna i'm an introvert you
wanna isolate you wanna withdraw and
when given the option you will choose
the path of least resistance which is to
be alone and have your own [ __ ]
uh but i think that it's i just i
personally think that it's important if
no it may be something that is so
it would ultimately putting yourself
through that would be unhealthy for you
i can't speak for everybody but i think
for most people making the decision to
learn how to share a living space with
another adult is is a great thing for
personal growth yeah i mean christy's
uh first
roommate in college it was a complete
nightmare situation
and then
i mean she was
if i recall the story correctly she was
like borderline abusive yeah like she
would have these
fits and she would like take it out on
christy like yell at her and it was
horrible and then at a certain point she
couldn't she was i think she was having
a breakdown and she ultimately
couldn't continue her first semester and
left
and then the the roommate that chris so
then yeah and then christy had her own
if you're in a situation like that yeah
you gotta i mean there's obviously your
stream situation we're talking about
normal healthy safe situations but even
a difficult i mean but even a difficult
roommate not an abusive roommate if it's
unsafe or abusive on any level then yeah
you got to get yourself out of that
situation but a difficult roommate
that could be that's could still be
something that you need to do you know
that could be sure because you could
learn how to be like hey let's have a
conversation let's communicate about
right let's communicate through this
problem you learn the ability to solve a
problem through communication with
someone that is something that you will
take and then apply in every single area
of life as you as you move forward um
only other thing i got on the on the
dorm front shower shoes yeah you don't
want to get the fungus like i have to
believe that we did use shower shoes
yeah well there was like seven things
that we were told by someone that we ate
orientation or something then one of
those were the shower shoes and we just
did it religiously
i was very committed to that i had to
have been uncomfortable taking a shower
next to other people taking a shower i
mean there were it was individual stalls
you couldn't see anybody you could see
feet you could see feet and then if you
were in the last shower stall you could
see the feet of someone taking it taking
a poop yeah and that was just
i don't like that i don't like showering
next to somebody taking a poop right so
i would always go to the i would go to
the other far side yeah shower that was
the most that was the the most
frequented one was the nearest one to
the door
away from the poop
machine i don't think i was ever
comfortable with the bathroom situation
but it was it was good for me to to
figure that out okay
next principle
that we would like to explore is the
idea of getting involved in something
okay you talking about clubs clubbing
again i i i believe
and this may not be true but it was true
for me and it's true for most everyone
i've ever known is that your potential
to be like
idealistic and passionate about a cause
peaks between 18 and 22 right
and
you the adults in your life will try to
tamper that down and we'll
we'll try to
be like ah you just control yourself a
little bit i actually think
that it's kind of an important formative
stage in life to like
throw yourself into something with
reckless abandon because the way that
your mind is developing and just the
stage that you're at
you have this just incredible capacity
to just go all in on something
with some other people who are going all
in on something i can't know what
blanket statement i mean you cannot tell
about a cult here uh no i mean again
all this comes with the the idea that
you got to use some discretion but let's
talk about what happened with us you
know channeling that drive and
acknowledging it and then acting on it
is an exciting thing i i mean i would
say uh i would say
i preface this with please choose a good
cause you know like yeah don't go get
involved in something just do it
bringing bad into the world getting us
up get get involved in something
that's bringing good into the world but
a part of being that age it's just kind
of difficult to know what's good and bad
because there's a lot of people who most
people believe that they're right most
people believe that they're what they're
doing everybody believes that what
they're doing and what they're putting
their time and energy into is the best
thing for them in the world right yeah
and that's what we thought again coming
into school as conservative evangelical
christians we knew we wanted to get
involved with campus crusade and boy did
we get involved with campus crusade
we've told the story of exactly how
involved we got to the point that we
ended up working for campus crusade
after we graduated
but being in the midst of people who
were so passionate about something
and who were like kind of following this
ideology and this philosophy with
reckless abandon to the point that it
was
um
it was kind of becoming uh
when you when you it be it became it
consumed a lot of your time
i yeah i regret the specifics at this
point in my life meaning that the things
that
that group stood for are not things that
i stand for anymore
and i have changed personally but i feel
like for me it was an important part of
like
needing to believe something with a
fervor and actually like know what it's
like to commit time and make sacrifice
to
just kind of go all in on something
i and maybe it's a personality thing but
for a lot of the people maybe it's
because i happen to be friends with a
lot of people who kind of came through a
similar situation where they were like
all into evangelical christianity and
then they
came out of it
but from a developmental standpoint like
believing something with fervor and then
no longer believing it
because i i'm not going to say the
prescription is get really into
something and then realize that it was
wrong later in life you can't write
somebody's script but you know it might
be like i'm going to like
the the uh
the group on campus that is is you know
there's so many different things that
are and it could just be like i'm really
into
intramural soccer right i mean that's
not not a cause but like yeah throwing
yourself into something that has
a structure and a group around it and i
i think some there's so many causes and
so many good causes that you can get
involved in or your interests as well
yeah yeah i do think it's valid um
just because i just think it ends up
leading you into some interesting places
you'll find yourself doing i mean for us
it was like we found ourselves going to
you know foreign countries or foreign
cities yeah during the summers
and going on retreats and spending a lot
of time with people again it rounds out
your experience we were talking about
serious stuff as a human yeah to
to commit yourself to something and i
like what you said the sacrifice
associated with prioritizing certain
interests passions or causes
is a is a big part of development
because you can't you can't do
everything even if even if all options
are good i really regret
never never
playing uh ultimate frisbee yeah i
seriously a couple weeks ago i was like
uh it came up in the car and christy was
like you know your dad's your dad's
great at throwing frisbee i don't know
where that
uh of course statement came from i don't
remember what we were talking about
and then i was like you know what i've
never played ultimate frisbee though
it's like really for someone as talented
as a
frisbee thrower as you you've never i
was like yeah i could that could have
been my thing you know running and
throwing and and state had like an
intramural program where you could have
easily played i i thought of
uh
ultimate frisbee as more of like
uh
a carolina or duke thing like a snooty
thing like i knew that it happened on
their campuses like there was a lot of
you thought a lot of things a lot never
shared with anybody ascot wearing
ultimate frisbee throwing you know frat
guys that was my idea of it that wasn't
for me i played a little intramural
soccer and and first you know and i
think this is definitely personality
based because some people just you know
some people
me and i will also speak for for a link
tend to kind of it's easy to kind of you
know
to get super passionate about
something and kind of those tend to be
people who like become really religious
at some point in their lives you know uh
and some people's personalities are not
wired that way so it might be like hey
just you know
being on the ultimate frisbee team i
don't need like an ideology to throw
myself at yeah i just need a group of
friends but
the reason i say a cause
beyond just an interest
is because because of that sacrifice
yeah you know it's just like something
where there's some kind of
action involved like we are going to do
this together we come together because
we're trying to accomplish this
thing in the world or this thing on our
campus
to me
it's just i think there's a
again it's just a developmental thing
obviously there's probably good that
comes out of it if you're doing
something for a good cause but for me
it's just it's harder to do that after
college
right it's very hard to do that after
college
um it is the time when your schedule
lends itself to
again not everybody
but your your schedule lends itself to
it's more flexible than it will be later
in life um
one of the things yeah i'm i don't know
if i want to open this can of worms
because we haven't even talked about
classroom and studying
but
maybe we keep it short but i did read a
piece of advice that i didn't know if i
agreed with because it just seemed
thorny that was as a freshman avoid a
serious relationship
now
i broke up with my high school
girlfriend going into my sophomore year
and
the period between
breakup and meeting christy it was like
there was a torturous period for me it
was like
it was it was
it was a tough
like half a semester or maybe most of a
semester
that was my the start of my sophomore
year but and i went home so much my
freshman year it's like once i broke
once we broke up finally at some
sophomore year
or it was the summer leading up to
sophomore year
it's like i i had these regrets
associated with things that i you know
hired hamstrung my freshman year so that
was definitely my experience and if i
had to do it over if i had a you know a
crystal ball and i knew that we were
going to break up
yeah i would have i would have done it
before i went off to college but yeah um
it's a really tough thing it's a tough
thing and like
you i don't like dictating
when you fall in love you fall in love
there's not much you can do about it i
mean if i was i don't if i was in my
not worrying about people's feelings and
just giving the advice that i truly
believe in mode which i usually am in
and then have to keep myself from being
that guy um i would say if you're
if you're going into college and you're
dating somebody who's still in high
school you got to break up with them
as a blanket general statement knowing
that there's all kinds of intricate
things but it's just
this is probably not going to last and
it's going to drastically impact your
college experience but you're the one
who did it so you need to be the one to
talk about it i'm just
i think the advice i give to you know
is
i'm not giving it here but maybe i i
think the way that i would give this
advice is more of like it's cautionary
tales it's like know what decision
you're making and the impact that it can
have before you start
dating somebody
a second a third time before you start
accelerating
that relationship if you're on the
precipice of going off to college
then
you know you
there's some caution that you can have
in making more of a calculated decision
instead of just a
i'm just going with the flow of it and
i'm just going the only thing i'm taking
into account
are my
my feelings
or my infatuation you know it's it's
it's better when you're
if if you're not in a serious
relationship and then like
over the summer before your freshman
year you can you can factor in other
things and and
besides just your emotions yeah
and you can maybe curtail but you could
be in but if you've been in a long term
maybe it's a long high school
relationship relationship yeah then
that's well no but i'm saying that even
if
even if you're in a long-term healthy
relationship you need to know that if
the person is not going to be at your
college with you
the reality is
is that
the gravitational pull to that person in
another place is going to have a drastic
impact on your college experience now
that may be something you just navigate
and
deal with and accommodate i'm not saying
yeah because if you really if you have a
healthy relationship you care about each
other and now it has to shift to being a
long distance relationship because one
or both of you are going off to
different colleges
well
if you really
care about that person
then you're going to want to you're
going to want to have a conversation
where you establish practices
and maybe even boundaries to allow both
of you
to
to to live the life separately to the
fullest you know yeah and because you're
gonna you're also in like you're in the
midst of so much change yeah you know
and i'm not i'm not here to [ __ ] on high
school relationships if if i if i could
you know that's an image if i could [ __ ]
right on high school relationships i
would do it no um definitely get
arrested for that the the advice i i
would give to high schoolers in
relationships is like hey just hold off
on it being serious as long as you can
but it's you know human yes it's it's so
difficult for people to not just
basically start treating each other as
if they're married to each other in this
strict monogamous exclusive relationship
like that just tends to be what people
do even in high school even though
you're changing so quickly
that it's probably not advisable but who
listens to advice right
but
you're just going to continue to change
and your environment is changing so much
especially if you're going away to
college now if it's a completely
different scenario for like oh i'm going
to the
local school i'm going to community
college i'm still living at home we're
still in the same place like that your
dynamics are in your relationships are
not are going to change that much right
so it's a case-by-case thing
but strongly consider it let's talk
about studying yeah classroom stuff i
mean
it doesn't matter really
well it's just like great let's just
let's just end it you know what you know
you don't learn anything
no i i i think we've we've got some good
stuff here because
this is what i would tell myself if i
could go back all right i treated
my class choice
i'm not going to talk about study habits
that you if you if you i got you guys
some stuff about that
if i could have treated my class choice
from a thinking from a different place
it was exclusively like what is going to
be easiest
now again i was getting an engineering
degree which i knew would be difficult
on its own but then
there's core classes that you have to
take but then there's the electives and
i made my choices about my electives
based on what i had heard like oh that
professor is really easy
or that professor is really nice but you
know the one thing i didn't consider
what i wanted to freaking learn about
yeah i took an intro to film class and i
i was horrible at it because you had to
write papers
and i hated that but it was an enriching
experience it was really eye-opening i i
i was i was i regret i regret not taking
that class i regret not taking that
class given what we do now yeah you know
and we were interested in video at the
that was you at least made the
connection to be like i'm going to take
this intro to film class because we were
like making videos i guess is why you
were doing it yeah but i i wasn't even i
was like well
i'll figure out how to make videos on my
own like
and then the one class that i took and
again i took it for the wrong reasons
just because somebody said it was easy i
know what you got the alternative
futures class yeah which i've talked
about multiple times with crazy
professor who wrote the textbook himself
and it was all in single spaced
no diagrams just text single space very
few paragraphs to be honest
and it was a fascinating class about
futurism and i'm so into that and i
didn't even understand that i was
because i never stopped to ask the
question what are you actually
interested in if i had to
put here's the thing
you'll read this in a lot of like
college advice articles but i do believe
that it's true you know once you're if
you're thinking about your gpa once you
get up above a 3.5 who cares the
difference between 3.5 and 3.9 or 4.0
for almost every job that you're going
to get it doesn't it doesn't matter
right and so f
do well in school have a good gpa but
think about the holistic experience and
what you're learning as an individual
because you also might find
oh this elective that i took
made me realize that this is what i
should be giving my life to this is i
should change my major
so just think about what you're
interested in let that drive your class
choice i wish i hadn't done it
and i hope that you do it i can um
run some of this stuff
by you see see what your
take is on it because i think there's
there's some nuance to at least this
first one don't skip class agreed i
think the nuance is
like
every class is really about
understanding the system like how to
it's like a game each class there's
someone in charge there's a professor
who's set up and they'll give you a
syllabus they'll show you how it works
it's like actually figure out how to
beat the game
that's what the syllabus is this is what
this is how much each thing is worth and
this is why we're going to be going
through stuff so you may find that you
can skip
a class
and still beat the game but don't start
there but that's a it's a bad idea to
start there and it needs to be a last
resort and it needs to be more about the
class than it is about whatever you're
skipping to do
like that your job is to go to class is
what i would tell lily that's your
profession is to go to class and study
and
but that doesn't take all of your time
but you need to protect that time and
then
prioritize all the other things that
we've been talking about around that
because it shouldn't take everything and
because it's a maturity thing but yes a
maturity thing you shouldn't you
shouldn't be skipping class so that you
can experience something else you should
be skipping class only if you have
reasons related to the class that you
don't need to be there or there's
extenuating circumstances so i'm not
going to say that doesn't exist because
there's certain classes that suck and
maybe you have to take them and
you know if you can if you can find a
way to pass the test in another way
without cheating of course
you know i think there's
there's room to bring some maturity to
those decisions
and i'm going to pair that with
uh go to office hours 100
and the reason why you're going is
because you're seeing if they offer
hidden rewards like a lot of professors
first of all if there's any opportunity
to like
make a connection with the professor
uh
get to know them or they know your face
and put to put a name with the face like
this is very important stuff whenever
you need to have a conversation in the
last half of the semester
where
you're not doing well
and you need you need to have a
conversation you're building social
capital with your professor is an
important thing that may come in very
handy when things get tight later on and
they reward people who show up at their
office hours and like give them the
answers like sometimes professors will
just give you the test basically before
the test say well i wouldn't yeah i
wouldn't worry i wouldn't really worry
about that type of problem but i would
worry about this problem they kind of
they like to give people an edge
they have office hours for a reason just
to give people an edge yeah right all
you got to do is take it it's so easy
and you don't have to go every single
time you can get an idea of again it's
part of the game
you know
this is what this person this is how
they approach office hours
they know my face they know my name i
accomplished that but now i'm not going
to go back to this person's office hours
because they're actually useless they're
a waste of my time but that's again it's
a maturity thing it's and it's about you
know again this can get a little
i know there's so many like advice tick
tocks these days
but
so we don't mean to like just sound like
a couple of dads but we are a couple of
dads and we have lived a little bit of
life and so i think that the
this is kind of what i tell my kids is
like learning how to position yourself
well for things like
when you enter into a situation where
they're in school is you know it gets
more complicated
frankly once you get out of school and
it's like you don't get a grade at your
job it's not like the semester comes up
and you're told it's it's it gets a lot
more gray this is the last chance that
you have to sort of have this
very specific path
that you've been given like link said
with the syllabus and you know exactly
what is being asked of you and you know
when you're supposed to show up and you
know what the assignments are
when you're presented with that
challenge and that set of challenges
there's also these things where you can
position yourself to succeed and have
leverage and have options when you skip
class
all semester like you do it like i do in
some dreams sometimes
and then have to show up for the exam
and you're not prepared and you don't
even know the professor's name
you haven't positioned yourself well
and
again some of it can seem like oh i'm
just a mouse running in a wheel well
this doesn't seem applicable and maybe
it's not maybe the specific knowledge is
not applicable but learning how to
submit yourself to a process and hold
yourself accountable and see what it
takes to be like oh i'm put in this
situation and if i do x y and z i get
this result that's a principle that will
last your entire life
right if you can figure out how to do it
in your early 20s
you'll be able to do it in your early
30s you'll be able to do it in your
early 40s
and that that's you know i'm not saying
my kids listen to me when i say it but
so i'll just throw it out to everybody i
think there was an
i know a lack of awareness on my part
not only in college but also when i
started working at ibm that like there
was a
there was another level of thinking
that's like you step back and you're
like all right this is this is there's a
system here there's politics involved
there's social interaction involved it's
not just about having the right answers
making their making all a's
and it's it's not just about
the specific tasks but it's about the
entire idea
of it and i i think that's really what
you're describing
that's like
would have changed my approach to have
more of a
um
whatever thousand foot view is the right
it's like you literally are a rat in a
maze to use a crude analogy and a lot of
times at that age you tend to just see
the maze right in front of you in the
left and right choice and you wait until
the choice sneaks up on you and then you
make it whereas you actually have the
ability to
get out of your body have an out-of-body
rat experience and get above the maze
and see oh this is the context of this
whole thing and this is how you get to
there oh and i can back up even further
and see the table that the maze is on
and the room that the maze is in and the
reason that this maze even exists
you've got to get to you've got to
elevate your thinking beyond just your
immediate circumstances and all of a
sudden you just zero back down into that
choice and you're like oh this choice
becomes much easier and much more
motivated because i understand
the context at the highest level yeah i
mean you talk about having an
out-of-body experience i also want to
say
um
you know
don't take any substance that somebody
gives you
especially if you don't know them uh-huh
oh god when i started thinking about
things like that those are the things
that i'm like i'm just passing lily in
the hallway of our house don't take any
substances don't take any substances
from anyone that you want keep an eye on
your drink at all times you know it's
just like i'll just pass in the hall and
i'll just i'll just give her little
things like important it's like say say
yes to invitations but always have
an exit plan where you are in control of
yourself
don't forg don't forget that you're an
adult now so act like an adult
another that wasn't mine that was a
piece of advice that i read and another
thing and maybe this is my last piece of
advice that i'm just
uh
quoting
be prepared to be overwhelmed
and they go further and say seek
professional help when you need it yeah
i think i you know
it's a huge transition
uh and
going back to the beginning of this
thing this it's it's such an opportunity
for a fresh start but everything is
going to be new
and it will be overwhelming
and making sure that you have proper
support structure you know that there
are people who love you that you can go
to or professionals that can help you if
you in certain ways that you that you
might need
establishing those lifelines are going
to be
very critical for anybody making any
huge
life change
and
this is big as any yeah and opening up
to people you know again i
i had the privilege of not dealing with
um
being overwhelmed or being super anxious
in college but i know that that is an
exception to the rule and i don't
exactly know what i would have done had
i had encountered those things right i i
do remember and i think i've told you
the story of
driving my riding my bike all the way
across campus past the dining hall in at
like the end of the first week of school
and i was like i'm gonna go all the way
to the far edge of campus and just see
so i can say that i've seen it all i've
seen the boundaries
and it felt like going to the edge of a
flat earth and i i got off my bike and
it was past the ut
dorms
it was kind of looking over i think
there was like where the baseball field
was
and i just remember standing there
as the sun was setting
and dismounted from my bike and feeling
like i just needed to cry because i was
like there's no more campus there was
well it just
it was a physical
reflection of
i think my mental and emotional state of
like i
am i'm on i am
i'm experiencing something
and i'm on the edge of it i'm on the
edge of the rest of my life and i it was
the first time that i kind of felt alone
and it was scary
and then i got back on my bike and i
rode back forgot all about it never told
anybody until now until you're 40.
um
okay well i mean i think we've covered
it if you listen to this you're ready
for college the definitive guide to
college you're going to succeed
you've got it you've you you've got this
summer come along um
you know what you know i do believe that
i do not believe that we've given you
the definitive guide to college but i do
believe that if you're about to go
to college you've got this
believe that and also
uh
just be ready to like link said be ready
to
communicate
if if if you start feeling like things
are unraveling or things are getting
tough like know what your resources are
going to be before you before you go in
but you and the network of people around
you you got this you got this i like it
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you disagree with
um i'll give you a question i'll give
you a quick wreck
um
unrelated to anything we talked about
just right now let's go
uh there's a documentary on netflix
called pray away
uh which is about the
ex-gay movement
oh
uh so there's like exodus international
you know is the big one
and i think it's mostly about that
i did watch it i don't mean to sound
like i didn't watch it
but essentially it's the
for a long time in the evangelical
church there has been
you know groups and especially exodus
international it was basically designed
for people who were in the words of
the evangelicals struggling with the sin
of homosexuality
uh
and it and it's an incredible story
about the people who were involved in
that group even the people who are
leading the group
who came to realize the damage that they
were inflicting on so many people
and kind of their stories people who
were in it and people who were leading
it
and it's just kind of just
really eye-opening
um
stories that will i and i think you know
regardless of what your background is
and regardless of what you call yourself
now regardless of your perspective i
think there's a lot to be
learned regardless of your position
um i think that
hearing you know these people's
heartfelt stories and told in an
impactful way is is important so pray
away
on netflix oh and one more thing
we are doing our second annual
live stream for charity the charity this
time is save the children that is a live
stream on gmm so the good mythical
morning we're gonna we have eight hours
straight it's we have a lot of good
things planned
classic gmm games special guests music a
lot of other stuff
all the benefits save the children so
that is
thursday september 2nd
noon to 8 p.m eastern 9 00 a.m to 5 p.m
pacific so mark your calendars to be
there for and don't skip class to be
there unless there's a class that you
could skip i mean i mean let's be
serious i mean some of you can it's for
a good cause good mythical morning
channel september 2nd yeah eight hour
stream we will see you then and we'll
you know what we'll we'll see you next
week like we always do
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best